show is also brought to you by my undies
go to meundies.com joey and check out
all their men's and women's underwear
and all their other products like
sweatpants shirts t-shirts socks all
their amazing products go to
meandies.com joey to get twenty percent
off of your first order or save eight
dollars a pair with the me on the
subscription plan and shipping is always
free in the us and canada meetundies.com
i'm slipping
kick that
muley i'm taking you deep in the murky
waters
of three [ __ ] black gay guys that
sing this song
i love that that here we go [ __ ]
if you ever saw the movie fx
this is the closing [ __ ] jam but who
gives a [ __ ] about movies
you got the church of what's happening
now
lisa
uncle joey
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
you haven't heard this in years have you
i've never heard it
jesus christ
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here
i got a long week in new york city so we
did this podcast uh to keep you going
for the second half of the [ __ ]
week
we were a little too too tuned up last
night tonight's just a mild night 1300
milligrams
22 bong hits you know just a mile
[ __ ] rough day i was telling lee that
the other night i'm sitting there
minding my own business on the couch and
at night the cats come out and they [ __ ]
around with you you play with one for
two minutes this guy comes over
and i was watching because what i did
was i went to season one of narcos he
just went back to restart it i had to
it's great i had no [ __ ] choice i
wanted to see the acting i wanted to see
what i missed i'm one of those idiots
that gets high at night
and i'm on stars and i try to watch an
episode i really don't watch it i'm just
sitting there [ __ ] drooling on my
shirt
and then i go back and i saw a bunch of
things i saw how tata grew and all that
anyway i'm sitting there and super bad
jumps on me and let's say he's on my
legs
if he's on my legs and i'm watching tv
he'll get right here on my left hand
side and he'll reach for me for my
shirt and once he reaches for him i
gotta de-clothe the shirt and then hug
him and play with him and that's how it
goes until he gets sick and tired of
[ __ ] being there
he's cool as [ __ ] you see how he was
with your wife that day oh yeah he's
he's cool as [ __ ] but you can't get rid
of him he's like [ __ ] the hurt you'll
never get rid of that [ __ ] if
you get love which i don't mind but yeah
you know he starts on you and then he
climbs if you have a nice shirt i can't
have him sit on you because you'll have
a thousand holes i look at my shirts and
a nice [ __ ]
[ __ ] shirts and i got holes in them
because that's he's a nightmare when he
jumps on you he always and he doesn't
mean it
he loves you he really [ __ ] is a
loving cat
doesn't harry do that but he does it
with like your legs with your legs yeah
harry always [ __ ] jumps and and holds
onto your legs and then pulls himself up
like a [ __ ] like i'm not olympus
you know and the next you know i got
three little bruce lee scars on my
[ __ ] leg
and i don't mind listen that's the cost
of having [ __ ] cats so
the other night he's like you know he
starts on your left side then you move
him and then he [ __ ] climbs on the
couch and then he eagerly creeps up on
your shoulder and he puts his nose on
your neck which again i i can't get mad
at him he's just a he's like a dog
superman's a [ __ ] dog you know
superman went from
one extreme to the other as an animal
super bad went from had no contact
and running outside when the girls were
sitting there were young kittens
to you can't get rid of him
it was just he's like the kid from in
the night
you know he went in a nice kid who came
out with a tattoo he's snorting heroin
that's uh super bad right and not in a
bad way he went from being completely
anti-social
just being super bad
just being [ __ ] super bad like that's
why i gave him that name because i
wasn't too thrilled with him when he
lived outside what would he do like why
would he they were [ __ ] kittens but
he was
buckwild they had a corner their mom was
on one side of the fence
and they were tiny babies on the other
and they went you know they would go out
and spread out first they would stay
three feet from the mom then they would
go out six feet from the mom and nine
feet from the mark
and as they got older and you i'd leave
at six in the morning and they'd be
sleeping with the mom still like cuddled
up it was cold out in la you know it was
that time of the year they'd be cuddled
up with the mom they had that little
corner i worried about that that was the
only real litter back there that i got
to see from a to z
for a while there was just cats popping
up and dying
this was like after a long stretch of no
kittens
this was her last litter
and then uh
she had those four cats okay
after she had had like [ __ ] six
litters back there
and the females that were growing up
they were having kittens back there and
the whole building was giving away
[ __ ] kittens and people coming and
getting kittens
and every morning you wake up and they'd
be a dead kitten when they were young he
would kill the father oh oh yeah samurai
samurai would kill him so
uh so he could [ __ ] get the mom again
give her a stabbing
so for some reason
i used to go out outside a lot in those
days it was 2007
and i would always i was doing uh
kenpo karate with these dudes okay and
they would always do forms
and i was
380
and they said to me listen man forget
about i want you to do this during the
week just to stretch out your joints
and get your legs thinner and i was
doing these uh tai chi things these
stretches so i would go outside and
they'd all be there
and i'd watch them
and
you know at one point there were six
eight weeks i don't know i'm not a
[ __ ] doctor i'm not a veterinarian
but i could see that
the rest of them would stay but like by
the we had a barbecue back there okay it
was a community barbecue was real clean
and [ __ ] it was 20 feet from when they
were born
where they were living and that's as far
as they would stray not super bad he'd
go on the [ __ ] roof
he get on the roof of the building he
got on the roof of the building he was
always like way ahead of the other three
[ __ ] kittens
and there was a boy
and he was crazy but not as crazy as
[ __ ] super bad
so i would it got to the point where i
would go upstairs and worry about the
three kittens i'd go super bad ain't
gonna be there in the morning because
he's so [ __ ] crazy he's gonna fight
with a possum
he's gonna fight with a raccoon or a
skunk that was raccoons back there
i would hear them back there at night
and i'd [ __ ] run down with a [ __ ]
stick and a shovel
it was that type of stuff towards the
end jesus
something happened one day i got home
and my wife was telling me that the cats
were sick outside that they weren't the
same as they were she was especially
that [ __ ] super bad
i know for a fact something's wrong with
them because that [ __ ] hasn't
moved in two days
so she hunted those cats down and tried
to save their lives and give him
vitamins and stuff you know just it was
just
it was surreal how many cats she had say
back there was her and a coretta and a
japanese lady
that went back there every day feeding
them to cats with milk from a bottle and
it was just
surreal it was like and then it died
down and we had those last four
and then we brought up the two boys and
the one boy died and i kept super bad
and then we gave the sisters away
sisters were gone for three weeks lulu
and evie right yeah
and the girl calls because i can't take
them they got to kill my cat
they were kittens but they were that
that blood was in them
the cat was giving them [ __ ] these two
girls were going really
and when they started circling the cat
and had a shadow put them in the
bathroom
evie's not a
kosher eevee moves as fast as a [ __ ]
snake and she'll take a chunk out of
y'all
you got to really watch evie that's why
evie don't come out evie knows that
she's badass
so she doesn't i saw demi [ __ ] around
with bad one day and she ran out of that
hole
and smacked didn't mean that four times
didn't know what had happened he just
ran away and she went right back through
a hole like nothing [ __ ] happened oh
my god the two girls lulu and evie
lulu's little old and fat now so she
can't move like she used to
but those two girls could throw a
[ __ ] beat on evie till this day i
don't put my face by evie
really yeah i don't put my face by evie
the only way i'll put my face by eve is
if she's looking that way and i'm
petting her from behind i kiss her in
the head
if you get evie riled up don't move your
hand real quick
that hand is history
she'll clock it twice and then bite the
fingertip
so you have to get her excited and for
her to turn and while she's turning you
go back and she'll turn real quick and
swap twice at it
jesus christ
that's such like a crazy thing to have
to know you have to know this with evie
evie doesn't you've never seen that
really you've seen them i don't really
play with lulu or even nah they don't
want to be played with they don't want
to be [ __ ] with they don't want to be
loved
lulu i got it lulu's my girl lulu i love
she's my princess really oh i was
playing with it when i started bleeding
from my nose this afternoon
lulu you gotta warm her up and then
she'll play with you she's the cutest
cat i've ever seen at that age her face
is just
it's uh
it's i've never seen a face like that in
a cat when you get her happy and she's
meowing really she's really cute and you
play with it you get like a string and
you play with it like you can play with
it for a long time
she's that type of cat but evie you got
to be kicked evie you'll leave on her
own
because she knows i'm getting pissed off
right like she'll say it to herself like
i'm getting pissed off at this
[ __ ] so i gotta leave like if
demi's dead and i'm giving demi love
when she comes up i gotta drop me
she doesn't want no games she doesn't
bother you a lot
she doesn't come out every night but
when she comes out
scrap and when i put him down as he's
leaving she'll swallow him and [ __ ]
he'll look at like what the [ __ ] just
for being there just for being there
just for [ __ ] principle
jesus christ
she'll come over and she'll let me pet
her head and rub a thing and call her
beautiful and then i pick her up a
little bit
and on her own she'll just take off and
that's it i think this is why cats like
get a bad name because this is like why
i don't have a cat like besides the
allergies this is my only experience
with cats either they hate or they were
mean
so like your cats are like the first
cats that are like
actually enjoyable to be around no
they're very enjoyable to be around
because
that's the love i've given them
you follow me you get what you give in
with anything right with anything and i
don't know the
at the point when i met terry that cat
was what i needed it's the dumbest
[ __ ] thing to talk about
but it really is
it was like i needed something
to take care he filled that void i don't
know i don't know because we hit it off
right away
and it got to the point where
it slowed me down a little bit i would
come home more in the afternoons instead
of staying out to dinner
just to play with them just to brush him
and check his teeth and the whole
[ __ ] thing i like them
but i would still do the same with a dog
when i had hercules i gave that dog all
the love in the world i had
i moved to colorado
in 85
and one day i'm sitting in my [ __ ]
house
and the door knocks this george burkel
kid i grew up with
and we had for all lived together for a
while and he had this dog sarge okay he
was an austrian shepherd sarge was
[ __ ] the goods
sarge was the goods he was just one of
those dogs that you lived in colorado
with
so george said i'm moving to take this
job
take
sarge you take them for me i said
absolutely
so from
maybe october of 85
to
maybe uh
january
no it was a little long i had i had him
up about a year and a half
so it was a little the time i'm off on
the time so what happened he gave him to
me when i came back from san francisco
so that was october
of 96 and i took him to aston with me
so the whole time i stayed in aspen
i had him
and one day there was a knock on my door
that's george burke never called and he
goes i need the dog back
and i didn't know what to do
i really didn't know what to do
i didn't know what i had to argue with
him i was going to keep the dog my
girlfriend at the time was heartbroken
and i was kind of heartbroken because i
had this nice apartment i was living
with her
you know we had a backyard i enjoyed my
time with [ __ ] sarge
so i gave george backsarge and within a
week
this guy george casakas
this greek
gave me this dog
hercules hercules he was a german
shepherd he goes he's yours
he was probably uh eight weeks old and
we saw just a little ball of fat
so when he gave them to me it was the
off-season my wife went back to the
girlfriend i was doing at the time went
back to boulder to be with her family
for like three or four weeks
so i had that dog for four weeks with no
work there's no work oh and it's not
snowing yeah this is the end of the
season everybody goes back to where
they're from people go back home and see
their family now
the stores are open very limited
very limited and you didn't want to go
back to jersey no i had no life in
jersey at that time the last place i
wanted to go was jerry's had nothing in
jersey so i stayed with this
[ __ ] puppy and i used to make
vanilla milkshakes
and i used to play pink floyd with him
all day and then when it would snow he
would shovel snow with me i mean it was
just like this four or five week bonding
then my girlfriend came back and uh we
took the dog we had the dog the dog was
ours like [ __ ] uh whatever 87 to i
lost them in the divorce in 94. [ __ ]
paula really likes dogs
she really and
i love dogs but that's honestly one
thing i'm worried about is i
don't i take it really seriously like i
don't
we've talked about it before about the
pea pads here and people who just leave
their dogs in crates all day i don't
think i could do that no
no
no
you know what this aids that you have
right now you're a couple years away
from making a move and getting a bigger
place
and at that place you attack your career
and your life will be a lot clearer you
know
the podcast market is growing companies
are popping up but companies are
approaching us you see how many
approaches we're getting now people
taking
finally people taking podcasts seriously
right yeah so you never know where you
might end up
once you end up somewhere and you got a
crib and you got a yard and a [ __ ]
thing but you know what what's your
future here in l.a living where you're
living with a dog
you're gonna walk into that [ __ ] park
every day i'm in my house two two
[ __ ] miles and two miles back
or you're gonna [ __ ] in front of your
house on laurel canyon what are you
doing well yeah there's no future
there's no future i have a neighbor who
does that and it makes me sad yeah
there's no future there's no fear and
you know what i like tomorrow somebody
says joey i'm going to shoot myself take
my dog i'm in a [ __ ] spot but i'll
take the dog
you know even if if i live on [ __ ]
laurel canyon i got no backyard nothing
to do especially if he's a big dog i
don't want a little dog
if i got a dog it's a german shepherd
again
playing instead yeah from start from day
one pick him up when he's eight get him
sent over from nazi germany
[ __ ] give him to mercy and watch him
grow
and just watch him go
my mom used to get him the females and
not neuter
so they would bleed once a month and
[ __ ] they were meaner than [ __ ] you
can't control them but they bond with
women it's crazy
it's crazy how intelligent of a dog they
are it really is how little nuances they
know they know a lot of little things
and they all have a quirk so some of
them bite you on the way in some of them
bite you on the way out
some of them are you know they all have
their little cork you know you weren't
with me yesterday i took mercy to the
park and there was a german shepherd
that was old and his hips were starting
to go
that's their knock that their hips are
weak
but by now technologies had a chains to
help those [ __ ] dogs hips something a
shot they could give them a birth or
something like that so who knows or
breeding but
and this sounds weird but i had a dog
from i think it was like seventh grade
and i think he passed away a few years
ago
yeah like two or three years ago
and it's sad because they become a part
of your family right and i don't know
and part of me is like i don't know like
my mom i've brought it up she is adam
and she doesn't want another dog
and part of me is like
i know maybe eventually i'll get one but
like
it's still a little bit weird like and
then
and this is a morbid way to think but
then when you're getting it like okay
this is like 10 or 15 happy years and
then
like it seems like it's it is setting
yourself up for sadness but well no no
no you can't think of it like that no no
no no you can't listen
when you [ __ ] get your your wife
38 you might end up [ __ ] sad you know
when you leave the house you might get
my meteor that's a horrible [ __ ] way
to live [ __ ] it who cares he might last
five years or ten years
and we move on we all [ __ ] move on
there's something that you know for the
last month you said to me you seemed a
little stressed out i was moving
i was a little upset about the live
nation gigs canceling but the the lining
of that was the carmine died
i called frankie last week and i go
frank i'm coming home i
i don't know why i would never bother
you i know you're busy with the elevator
company
and he goes what's up i go i'm having a
hard time with carmine's debt can you
come over and let's do do breakfast
and for some reason i broke down right
there i didn't complain to him i just
cried by my own i hung up and i cried
more and i felt a lot better now that i
came up with
with that we all move on from that stuff
you know no matter how horrific it is
for some people it takes longer than
others but uh
listen fidel died and my wife and i had
a conversation the cat fidel
that [ __ ] ally really misses fidel
she goes my wife is like i know for a
fact
she changed as soon as fidel got she got
really sad because when
we brought ali in she was a [ __ ]
kitten and she took to fidel like
sometimes a big cat takes to a little
cat no she followed fidel everywhere
in fact we took him to the vet one time
and the vet was like what's going on
ellie like he was like a foreigner
trying to be cute
and my wife goes she's got a crush on
fidel and he goes no no no no fidel is
too big for you
that was a [ __ ] animal at the time
you know he's 20 [ __ ] pounds she's a
a
a nine-month kitten
but she would follow fidel everywhere so
she uh
when fidel died she's
you know death is weird and death with
animals is weird i mean some people my
friend called
keith conte what maybe four weeks ago he
told me he goes dog my cat died i i
haven't been the same for two months
because she used to watch football with
me for the last [ __ ] 15 years you
know
it's like a kid but uh
i'd rather have loved and not loved at
all
the thing i love my animals i [ __ ]
love them i love my cats
i love coming home at night the feeling
of coming home and bombing
or some [ __ ] [ __ ] says something
to you at the store and you just get in
your car and
you drive up laurel canyon pissed off
and you [ __ ]
make it right and stop at 7-eleven and
get some nicotine gum when i walk in
there's always one of those
[ __ ] awake waiting for me
he hears me park in the car
and they come up to you like you know
what's going on what do you got in mind
and you're like let me slow down a
couple minutes i'll come out here and
play with in five minutes and that's
what i do i go in i take my jacket off i
make some notes whatever
i smoke a little bit and i go right back
in the living room and that air
and i put the tv on and i hug them and i
kiss them
then they
disappear sometimes they hang all night
sometimes they hang for [ __ ] 10
minutes
but it's it's [ __ ] something that you
cannot describe whether it's a cat a
parrot
a snake however you look at your pet
you know it makes i make fun of it
because sometimes i don't understand it
but i do understand the service pet
industry
i just don't understand bringing him on
the front plane and [ __ ] up my world
but i do understand the comfort that a
an animal gives a human being and vice
versa i really understand that i've seen
it
i believe in it i know there's times
with me when i'm getting a rough day
and without even knowing
they jump on me and i'm on the phone and
somebody wants me to email him and as i
go to get up i'm about to push the cat
i'm gonna go whoa whoa whoa whoa look at
this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] nose i'm going
through today
haven't they like stopped you from
passing out before they stopped me from
passing out they've stopped me from
cursing out a [ __ ]
you know they really do they're calming
and there's tests there's some research
and i didn't i don't want people to
think uh there's research that states if
you own a pet you live a couple years
longer i can see it i don't know what
the three years for dogs or seven years
for dogs and three years
longer for cats people who have pets
throughout their lives
and i get it i get that little uh
connection i get that the feeling of
buying your cat a 200 [ __ ] hanging
post
and going you know uh
you deserve this
when i come in you know whatever
sometimes you cook and they come over
and [ __ ] with your world
and you're like you're not getting none
of this but they're like you know what
we're not leaving
till we get a piece
so you better [ __ ] get your head
together
and once you know that you're like okay
let me just give a [ __ ] piece of
cheese they'll disappear and they'll
stop bothering you cool whatever the
[ __ ] i'm making whipped cream you know
ice cream whatever the [ __ ] there's
always one of those [ __ ]
that wants a [ __ ] action of what i
got i was going through the old matt
flavors world videos and we had some
where uh you were giving uh finney ham
and he would just and i even forgot well
the first one the first like matt
flavor's world we did
you had uh finney and he was like making
a meow like you would talk to him when
you make a meal like vinnie what are you
doing come here let me run away oh my
gosh i just got pissed
and he [ __ ] run out of that room and
then he come back three minutes later
it's uh
yeah i had my dog and
i like that was the only time i've ever
cried in front of paula to be honest and
we were in a car so i don't even know if
she saw but you know how many times do
people on saturdays go somewhere and
just ride a horse
they own a horse you know like a [ __ ]
horse that don't run in races why would
i want a [ __ ] horse
when i was 30 i figured out that people
like me smoke a [ __ ] dub
put that [ __ ] hard hat on and those
little horse boots
and they go for a [ __ ] they know how
to ride a horse professionally not
professionally like doing shows or
whatever
but they know exactly where to go when
they take a [ __ ] three or four hour
horse ride can you imagine what that
feels like well it'd be great on your
horse while he's [ __ ] he stops
he jumps up and does that [ __ ] lone
ranger thing horse people take a lot of
pride in it because they go and they
like clean their hooves this is all it's
a big thing this is
when you look at those guys on baby like
look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] brushing his
horse he should hire somebody but no no
no you don't hire nobody for that you
can't hire somebody for that
you lose the [ __ ] patois
if you hire somebody it's when you brush
out you know how much i love brushing my
cats
you do it like every day don't you yeah
i have two
that i brush every day
papa and i have a system so they don't
lose their mind because they get over
stimulated yeah they [ __ ]
so there's a way you brush and then you
pat them with your hand and then both
you know to give them love with the hand
to control him then i give him the brush
again with the hand and both you know
it's really interesting i didn't read
this i [ __ ] learned it by doing
by seeing what it did how it calmed them
down
and made them feel more or whatever at
ease yeah
so these little things you just [ __ ]
learn by saying i'm a [ __ ] cat pro
just because
i watch my wife
and i watch them and i watch you know
and for years growing up i was a dog pro
i had dogs all along
all along to the minute my mom [ __ ]
croaked i had a [ __ ] dog
i started with champion and i died with
[ __ ] crystal
who i would break into nina's house from
time to time into the yard and go in the
doghouse with crystal after my mother
died that was the saddest thing ever
i think about that [ __ ] dog all the
time and how bad i felt the life that
dog lived that dog died like me he went
from [ __ ] living in a house with an
air conditioner people giving you love
to live in a [ __ ] yard with nina
and i couldn't take the dog there was
nothing i could do with the [ __ ] dog
that's terrible i was living at
somebody's house
they can't walk up with a dog so no i've
had uh
my horrible experiences with dogs and
cat heartbreaks and i've had to justify
it
so
this is why i have this because it's a
completely different universe
and sometimes you [ __ ] up in that
universe let me get another cat or a dog
and make it right this time and
give that dog and i've always given my
animals tons of love that's the i've
never might convict my dogs or animals
i've always given them tons of [ __ ]
love that's why those cats act the way
they do
always always
you know you feed them personally you
see them they watch
they appreciate all those things also
it's really [ __ ] interesting you know
do you think
do you think you're misunderstood
i don't know no because i was thinking
like cats have that negative connotation
and and
sometimes i'm among people and like i've
i've been think thinking about you and
your special a lot just because i was i
got to go to austin it was great
and
i was like
because you have this uh
reputation and then but then but then
you go and you want like we opened the
the podcast with a song by a gay black
group and then we're talking about how
much you love your cats
and i feel like sometimes
some people's first impressions of you
might not be that you love that stuff
and maybe i'm wrong maybe maybe you
don't feel that but
no but that's the beauty of it they got
to look a little deeper
you know that's the beauty that we all
have when we do that [ __ ] up that's why
i did the mad flavors worlds
listen i could come on
here and make a list
of the things people want to talk about
i could come on here and i know the
music to play for people that they'll
jump up and down to right that's not
what i want to do that they hear all the
time that's cool that's not what they
want to do i do it from time to time
in the mornings play that type of music
to get people riled up
i could be a [ __ ] yes man you know
what i like about cats the reason people
hate cats
they don't come to you when you call
them
they have their own world
they will live
they live the [ __ ] life
by their rules a cat
a dog you walk in you call him over he
jumps on your lap
you know the whole thing he licks you in
the face a cat
when i'm ready
when i'm ready so people can't deal with
that
uh disconnection i can because i'm the
same [ __ ]
don't tell me to do something let me do
it on my own
that's my specialty you don't have to
tell me
i don't want you to [ __ ] tell me
i'll do it on my own i don't ever want
you to say hey you got to pay the rent
on these don't tell me that
i'll do it on my own
and that's what you love about cats
that's what i love about cats that
mental freedom that attitude
which is what people don't like or
respect
they want to command their animal to
come and hug whatever cats are
completely on their own [ __ ] realm
do you think i wasn't really when i
liked dogs i wasn't really a fan of the
cat
i didn't hate the cat i wouldn't lie the
cat on fire throw a rock at that
[ __ ] thank goodness but i didn't
own a cat if i went into your house and
you had a cat i avoided that
[ __ ]
and i remember going to homes and
people's cats would jump on and they'd
do it super bad
and harry do now and they would be
scared to death and they would go no no
no that means he likes you and i would
go what the [ __ ] kind of animal likes
you by putting his claws in your [ __ ]
leg [ __ ] that [ __ ] bat with [ __ ]
legs
i hated cats but it wasn't that
i would shoot them or run them over the
[ __ ] car you know since i was a kid i
go out of the way for squirrels you know
i don't want to [ __ ] hit a squirrel i
still don't think i would pick up one of
your cats i love all your cats i don't
think i would go i'm still a little bit
harry would let you pick them up really
dimmy wouldn't
super bad battle let you [ __ ] him in the
ass you don't give a [ __ ] you can pet
him for an hour he'll let you [ __ ] him
in the ass
ally won't let you pick her up none of
the girls will let you pick him up
i i i wouldn't even know how to go about
it just sneak up behind harry harry will
drop and you just rub him by the stomach
harry's the one that'll do it the most
he'll let you the most
harry and super battle at you the most
but you can't have fear in your hands
right yeah that's what i have
you cannot have fear in your hands and
that's a complete other thing you have
to learn over the years i got bit so
much by dogs that i i got rid of that
fear i mentally [ __ ] got rid of that
fear
don't get me wrong when i was coming up
here before the black [ __ ] fighter
was outside with that pit bull that
looks like a [ __ ]
one of those devil dogs that protects
the devil you ever see those dogs that
protect satan that's what that dog look
like
that dog gets a hold of my fat little
[ __ ] tire that's over it's like a
chinese buffet you wanted to go in
austin texas you leave everything you
know i had [ __ ] oyster balls
my thigh you know but
you can't walk in front of him like
you're scared i went right up to the
owner and said how you doing man the
whole time walking out i'm [ __ ] my
pants in just a little area of my body
not old school when i was eight and i
[ __ ] my pants when i saw a dog you know
yeah those kind of dogs can get scary
yeah so you have to control your fear
around those [ __ ] the same way
i gotta control my feel before i go on
stage it's it's
once you do it one time you you say to
yourself how the [ __ ] did i do that and
then you go okay now i i got trained
when i was finally like 18. my friend
stinky
had that [ __ ] coco dog the
german shepherd
and every time you walked in there the
guy was like [ __ ] liberace you know
he'd suck your dick he'd light your
cigarettes but as soon as you told coco
you gotta go he'd take a chunk out of
your ass
really you tell me to leave oh my god
i've never experienced it get the dog
put him in the bathroom you gotta run
out of the [ __ ] house
or if not he'd bite you in the pant leg
or he'd take the bottom of your league
gene
jesus he never really bit you hard you
know it was just to scare you to not get
up
did you have a dog when you were
homeless
did you have no none of that
i was not going to be one of those guys
that was going to take a [ __ ] dog
down a bad street like that you know i
didn't know if hercules no no no
divorce right yeah no hercules uh lived
with me
all the way till before i went to new
york city
i left hercules with danny and my
ex-wife called danny and said did joey
call you he said for me to come over and
pick up the dog i never
told my wife that
and she went over and picked up hercules
and then it was hercules again
did it bother me
it was all rolled up in one [ __ ] big
ball of [ __ ] you you know right yeah so
you can't really dissect i really can't
[ __ ] dissect it
but no i like uh
i like my pets
the next couple days when i go home
i miss him i miss him so much
like i swear i just saw one
oh in the hotel room in the hotel room
late night like 12 i'm watching tv i'm
relaxing i'm writing i got glasses on
i could feel one like i could see one
when i walked by like what the [ __ ] am i
thinking i'm not home
i i know you i know you never would with
your cats but if you had a cat that
wasn't like attached to the group would
you bring a cat on the road if they let
you no
because i don't want him on the plane
i think that's cruelty to animals what
they do under the [ __ ] plane to that
they don't recover from that [ __ ]
brain trauma oh yeah you know if i fly
two hours with a cat what i hear and
what that cat hears just two different
noises
he thinks he's going to [ __ ] die he
hears the bottom of that plane you see a
plane going over yeah
think of being in the engine of that
plane and being an animal
it's three hours of [ __ ] horror
and in the meanwhile they're listening
to other [ __ ] animals meowing and
wolf wolfing and [ __ ] crying and [ __ ]
you know so
i hope
i can't for me i know people do it and i
see dogs on the other side when people
are there the dogs fly out and they hug
the [ __ ] owner
and they go it's great to see you don't
ever [ __ ] do that to me again yeah
well they're they're letting someone
play like i know for like the uh the
service animal thing but they also don't
they just let dogs like in the carriers
in the plane now or no it has to be a
service animal it's gonna be a service
animal or in the back
it's gotta be like paula's dog no pug no
in a little bag and they can't walk out
of that [ __ ] bag
so if paula wants to go to new york at
six and a half hours
what you gonna do that dog wants to piss
as [ __ ] yeah it's bound to piss as [ __ ]
that dog shits next to me i got a stab
ball in the middle you understand me and
you too oh yeah
so because that dog's that shit's gonna
stink that's why they put those planes
down
because you've never smelled dog [ __ ] or
[ __ ] [ __ ] a dog shits on a plane
that's when it gets it's like big macs
big macs smell great when you walk by
bring that [ __ ] on a plane
open up that big mac you want to puke
you want to barf
i i i tried to bring uh what is it
called trail mix on the plane and i had
to close it i felt bad and i opened it
it'd smell like ass so i can't imagine
what have you been on a plane that had a
dog [ __ ] yeah
and they had to take it down i got on a
plane one time with a dog [ __ ] as we got
on the plane
maybe six years ago and they had a plane
like we had we were 30 minutes out we
had to walk to another plane
but the whole tunnel stuck
from the [ __ ] uh when you come in you
know you give the lady a ticket right
you smelt it right there and they're
like what what's that smell and people
like oh my god and then people started
walking down
and the dog had gone in and right where
you turned to get on the plane he deuced
right [ __ ] there so the plane smelled
that way and that way i don't know so
they were talking about picking it up
and putting it away but it was dog it
was brutal it was [ __ ] brutal
and you can't blame the dog it doesn't
know what's going on who you going to
blame
the [ __ ] person who brought that
[ __ ] dog on the [ __ ] plane really
you're going to have a nervous breakdown
today [ __ ] when you outside you
were talking on the phone jumping up and
down talking about the yankees now
you're gonna have a [ __ ] nervous
breakdown
that's what pisses me off
you know that really you gotta bring the
[ __ ] thing take a valium like
everybody else take it i'll give you a
star of death you won't know nothing you
won't have any emotion the only emotion
you have is your heart breathing as you
pass out you're going to wake up in
philadelphia where the [ __ ] you're going
you're going to go jesus christ joey i
need those all the time all these guys
that have that fear they all take xanax
you know and they pass out just go to
sleep
i have the same fear but i can't go to
sleep no more i fell asleep in the plane
from austin the other day really oh yeah
you didn't sleep today i'm happy you
went to austin it was so much fun
we got to see you you spooked you got to
meet some people some new [ __ ] people
people knew who you were oh yeah oogie
spooky was like the most excited person
i've ever seen and her mom was there
character of [ __ ] love we were
texas i've been thinking a lot about
texas since we came home that's uh
i need to start going to texas more
often man
i'm definitely going to houston
i booked dallas tonight i'm going to go
to [ __ ] dallas and go to the chuck
and jive and eat some [ __ ] gumbo and
some jambalaya
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah there used to be a record
store there too
and you go in there and any record you
need it was right there bam they also
had a [ __ ]
ice cream place they got a japanese
steakhouse it's a fun [ __ ] three days
later
we might have to take in this to the
kennedy suite
this week where he slept the night
before he got shot and [ __ ] my dad did
radio in dallas
out of like
yeah he was in his 20s yeah he was there
way before you oh yeah way before me he
has he has tacos named after him and a
place and it had like mozza balls it was
like a joke taco but he was like on the
radio so
they like named it dallas is a good city
also dallas is like i said the other day
uh there's a lot of great [ __ ] cities
in texas and i went to all of them i
caught my comedy teeth in texas yeah and
they didn't give a [ __ ] they didn't boo
me they didn't throw [ __ ] at me
you know it's uh
i don't know if this back pain has been
stress or the move or
you know something that's been on my
mind that's been bothering me the last
couple weeks which i've had a couple
things that
have been eating away at me lately but
nothing serious just you know
different situations i have to get into
if this situation goes down do i really
want it that type of [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying i'm really happy with lee
just sitting there doing a podcast
but now if they offer you this do i
really want to [ __ ] drive to god with
studios i'm [ __ ] spoiled now
i don't think i could be told what to do
anymore i really can't
i did it for a long time guys i did
those movies and those tv shows
and i got to tell you something i was
never one to kiss ass or take pictures
or whatever
i talked because you have to be sociable
so i talk to different people and
there's people i really like
and there's people i saw right through
but you think you you're listening to me
going joey are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
exactly well here's the thing guys
it's a complete different thing
than selling a show and owning your own
show and having your own show
then doing somebody else's show or
somebody else's [ __ ] movie
and
you know man when you have the freedom
of being a stand-up
you know like i have the freedom of i
love to shoot a movie or a tv show for
three weeks you know just to get me the
love stand up that much more
and then i do stand up for six months
and i'm like [ __ ] i gotta write new
material hey you wanna do a movie for
six weeks [ __ ] yeah it gives me a chance
to write new [ __ ] material
and not really give a [ __ ]
that's the system i wanted
but with all the [ __ ] union things
and the insurance and all the
differences it's like you know what man
they gotta pay me to be unhappy
you know what i'm saying i mean it
sounds like a [ __ ] whiny thing to say
but we've discussed this a thousand
times on this podcast of being happy
that that's the most important [ __ ]
thing that
i'm scared to sign on for some lee and
after four days i want to shoot myself
in the mouth well i think that that's
what i'm [ __ ] scared of late to be
honest with you doesn't that happen to
everyone when they start a new job i
mean
i think that's and i think what the
difference is going to be is when you
started 20 years ago
if you call me tomorrow and go joey i
want you to work on something for one
day do me a favor as personal
if i read what you wrote for me like
marin did and i could have a good time
and get high and go down there right
[ __ ] yeah i'll go down there two days
with my main man lisa
but if you're gonna write like some
guido mafia stuff for me
i gotta be geno and i'm the boss i can't
read that no more i can't read the
[ __ ] i'm a butcher well i can't read
none of that [ __ ] no more that's what
i'm trying to say to you absolutely the
last three [ __ ] television
experiences besides mayor and i had
lee were horrible really
horrible horrible i got to be honest and
people at home are probably going to
enjoy what the [ __ ] experience be
horrible you ever not want to be
somewhere that's horrible okay
when i first got here i got booked on
like a show on nbc that i didn't know
what i was doing at all guys you ever
walk into something you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're doing
you ever walk into something you really
don't know like you really don't [ __ ]
know like where to start like i didn't
know action
basketball i didn't know dick
they made a [ __ ] they made fun of me
those guys just made fun of me i didn't
know nothing about action
i didn't know about cut i didn't know
nothing i went to acting class and i got
what was that we just talked about show
on nbc when i was a plumber for four
episodes
and i got to tell you something guys i
didn't know dick about dick they were
telling me to get to my mark
i didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
talking about that's the line where you
stand for the camera like i'm not here
to lie to nobody i knew nothing
and those people were nice with sidney
poitier's daughter
oh wow and it was john aston's son and
it was all sons stars of sons
sons and daughters of different stars
there was three of them out of the six
in the cast and i got a recurring role
as a plumber lee the first two episodes
i knew nothing
they were so nice they giggled about it
they thought i was just playing like a
goof i wasn't playing a goof i really
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
and once i got nailed there i went back
to acting class and i kind of [ __ ]
picked it up a little bit and then
you go along the way and all those
experiences were good along the way i
had some shitty ones while i was
shooting but it didn't matter
it was something i wanted to do it was
something i thought
would take me to the next level okay the
longest shot i was happy as [ __ ]
but along the shot i pissed off a lot of
people because i took matters into my
own hands
what do you mean i just went straight to
app for everything i didn't [ __ ] ride
with the rest of the mafia i just went
straight to the [ __ ] godfather
why am i gonna [ __ ] with the messenger
why am i gonna [ __ ] with all these
messengers all these producers wanted me
to talk to him i wouldn't talk to nobody
i wouldn't even talk to the [ __ ]
director i would just go right to adam
adam i want to wear the jock
adam i want to take my shirt off adam i
want to do this
i would improvise and he would cut me
off which was fine i'm not going to go
up and ask him permission dangerous
people don't ask her permissionally
you do it you go balls out and watch
them go that was [ __ ] great
you know when it comes to that realm of
acting and stuff like that with people
you never asked permission
i asked permission to wear a jock
because obviously i didn't have one and
stuff like that
but if i would have thought of that the
night before i would have showed up with
a job the next day but i wasn't that
good at that time my mind didn't think
that way i i thought about it while i
was there and i saw the locker room
setting
i didn't see it while i was reading it
do you understand me right but you
always come prepared and you just do it
and let them tell you [ __ ] no
and that's a scary thing to do
especially when when people go to like
jobs and stuff listen as a stand-up i
can't go up there and [ __ ] around
when i got serious about this it was
because i became dangerous on stage
not that i was going to take out a gun
and shoot the audience and i thought i
was that funny
but what i mean by dangerous is have no
bounds
to be good
at this realm of what we do
you have to really have no bounds you
and i have discussed the
the thing about people uh
doing stand-up and keeping a day job you
want to have discussed this many a night
over a [ __ ] uh a joint or a bung or
just us bullshitting about life in
general or managing comics
we've discussed how you don't want you
going with a job get him work because
he's not really fully committing
i know ten funny guys right now that
have not
that or the world doesn't know because
they kept day jobs
and that was the thing that held them
back it's such a hindrance
and sometimes you have a family you have
no choice you need the insurance you
know who am i to judge you
but kennison was dangerous pride was
dangerous
hicks was dangerous carlin was dangerous
so your work so that's what you're
worried about you're worried that you're
gonna get too much other work and not be
as dangerous on stage no what i'm saying
is that when you act you have to be
dangerous the same way you're dangerous
when you do stand up a lot of people
don't understand that okay when i go to
an audition i have a checkpoint list
that i got from lou de giamor
a cast and directing thing i did that my
wife bought me we were starving
and she paid 200 for the course on a
sunday ucla and i went there and i saw
brian calm that i'm i'm talking in 2000
in 2001.
15 years ago i saw a calendar an acting
workshop
and we were [ __ ] giggling our asses
off while we were there but he gave you
a worksheet that i kept
i made copies of it i'll never lose it
and sometimes i use it for stand up i'm
using it now for the special
and he always says don't apologize
go in there but go down in a blaze of
glory
you know that's what you need to do to
be good you need to go down the blaze of
glory when you go up there
you know anytime listen you know why we
it was great to bring josh adam myers
because i
explained to him that i had an anxiety
anxiety attack on stage
let me show you but do you know how
close i was getting from just [ __ ]
flabbergasting and dropping on my back
lee and then just flopping on the stage
really [ __ ] yeah i couldn't breathe
every time i jumped up and [ __ ]
waved my arm and [ __ ] that's like
aerobics class and i gotta sing at the
same time are you [ __ ] kidding me i'm
not janet jackson i'm not trained to do
that [ __ ] jesus i didn't know that yeah
like i could have [ __ ] flabbergasted
that's why i would take a break in
between lyrics
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with joy bananas and it was funny
because someone came up to me right when
you went on stage and i was like he
looked like he was falling asleep before
you going on you had gotten like so
relaxed
and then you went with where
went up there and went crazy i had no
idea you were having well before that's
what you i'm trying to become dangerous
the only way i'm going to become
dangerous is take it all the way to the
other end
and then we just sat there we both had a
drink right yeah what do i have a drink
never never had a drink that day
you know i don't know but that's one
thing i always remember whether it's
stand up acting
if you're going to be a good singer you
got to be dangerous what does that mean
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're gonna
do
you know what you might change the lyric
on me
and really [ __ ] my world up because i'm
a hardcore [ __ ]
fan you following me
which that you got to push the envelope
a little bit
that's what i'm trying to say if you
want to be in that realm you know if you
want to be an actor comic musician
you got to push the [ __ ] realm a
little bit
is it is it similar to sales can we we
we had in texas we had your friend and
i'm sorry i'm blanking on his name right
now jim jim handy jim hanley that talked
me into doing stand-up comedy and you
guys were just talking about taking guys
in who wanted to come in and buy like a
2 000 used car game for like a 15 grand
brand new car and just hysterical and
just pushing the envelope pushing the
envelope but there was a guy there who
taught me
he was dangerous his name was marty
sadler i talked about him a lot he was
from buffalo new york
today he's still a great he's general
manager but i hear he still gets out
there and [ __ ] wrestles people
and tells people to go [ __ ] themselves
and talk chinese to people you know
it was a different world and you could
talk a different way he was always a
gentleman he had four kids
and four boys and a beautiful wife and
i learned a lot from him because he
would say things not perverted or
anything
but he would say things that i would
never think of saying at that time to a
customer
and what he was doing was what i do to
lead today
he was teaching me what to do
how this is only going to work and until
i took his advice was i started clicking
do you know what i'm saying to you
so like you really it's kind of like it
is me okay i'm too nervous to do it okay
he would
for people who don't know in the car
business is a thing called the four
square okay
you come in you look for a car for
what's your budget lee my budget is uh
ten thousand ten thousand dollars okay
ten thousand dollars
i could possibly put you in this one the
cost of this car is ten nine nine nine
okay
lee what do you want for your [ __ ]
2015
vw what do you want for the car
twenty thousand twenty thousand twenty
[ __ ] thousand it's a beautiful
colleague by the way what's the mileage
on it
uh i think like ten thousand ten
thousand beautiful and it's a two
thousand wetley i think it's a sixteen
sixteen okay how much money do you wanna
put down
i don't wanna put anything down
we're gonna have to put something down
to finance this
vehicle i don't have any money to put
down the bank always want to put
something down so you're telling me your
car
you want 20 000 for your [ __ ] car
yeah what do you owe in the car
20 000 20 000. so you got nothing right
you have to come up with down payment
for me to trade this [ __ ] car
i know you have something in the bank is
there something you can give me on
friday
how much can you come up here with a
check for on friday can you come up with
2 000 2 000
i don't have 2 000. but what do you have
what can you give me on friday i could
take to my manager right now by the way
i'm going to need something right now
the atm card right now
just give me your atm listen for me to
get him to do business i got to bring
him something
let me get your atm card what am i gonna
have a limit though yeah it's like a 200
we don't give a [ __ ] it's okay as long
as he knows you have a credit card and
we could contact the bank and you have
credit you're a good guy you have a car
you have a brand new car i know your
credit's good
all right so friday you're going to come
here with 1500 1500 yeah you said you
couldn't do two so i'm just let's do
1500. and what do you want no i can't do
15. so what can you do 12 can you do 14.
14 teeth
yeah i guess okay let's do 14 on friday
what's friday's date friday's date is
the 24th all right
and what's your payment a month what do
you want to pay what are you paying on
this car here uh
250. and what do you want your payments
to be now uh 200 how much 200. and how
many years do you want the
payment to go
four four years okay beautiful let me
get that atm card real quick so i can
bring it to my boss and make sure i want
you to initial all these right here
and let's go do this paperwork when i
get back what am i signing you're not
signing nothing you're just initially
listening you want to pay 200 a month
all right for four years that's 48
months you're gonna give me uh 1400 on
friday
you're going to pay me 109.99 for my car
and 20 000 for your car i'm going to
give you 20 000 for your car i'll
initial all four of these real quick
i i can't do that i don't that's a
that's like a contract
not a contract for me to take this to my
boss you just gotta initial these come
on i don't have that much time i'm
trying to get you a good deal the other
guy that comes at lunchtime is a [ __ ]
pain he ass
i'm sorry to talk this way but i want
you you seem like a nice kid and i got
an idea
okay
all right boom let me get the atm card
the atm card
because i gotta see that he knows
something i got the credit up on you i'm
gonna run the credit up and make sure
this was all him right here
this is all him he was just beating you
up until you gave it to him oh my god
did you see you told me you wouldn't do
two times as soon as i asked you for two
what did i do i knew you only
i know you only have 500 in your pocket
but i said two because it's so high what
did you say 2 000
okay so you could do 15.
you agreed on it yourself i didn't even
do nothing
that's the trick that's the trickery of
this [ __ ] foursquare
and he taught me how to work this
foursquare but what he was teaching me
was
not the foursquare he was teaching me
about [ __ ] lively it's so funny how
this works for me even today oh my god
like you just get trapped it's like it's
like an octopus it's a trap
it's a jiu-jitsu trap
it's a brilliant [ __ ] trap
so how does the foursquare work you just
you go so now i come back and i say
listen good [ __ ] news okay all right
we got your 14 for your car
14 what thousand what about 20. huh it
was 20. yeah but listen we called three
other volkswagen dealerships the most we
get is 14 000 for your car
we're gonna sell you our car
for 9
500.
yeah you're gonna give us
1400 on friday and i got your great
sweet deal
i got you 249 a month no that's what i
was paying now for eight years eight
years
but listen that's a good deal listen
after two years you come back in we redo
the [ __ ] paperwork what i'm gonna do
is
uh and that's it he just bought the
[ __ ] car he's just confused because
you're down six thousand on that carly
so automatically that gets attacked to
this
so this car right now goes to [ __ ] 16
000
you're gonna give me 1400 down
and the best payment i could get you
right now you know what let me talk to
him again i'll get it down to two and a
quarter
but guess what
you're gonna sign for that and then when
you go into the box i'm gonna get you
for taxes so i'm gonna get you for two
and a quarter times twenty dollars
you're gonna pay me 245 it's [ __ ]
crazy
but today today i'm the reason why
because i gotta [ __ ] argue with
people all the goddamn time about this
[ __ ]
is why i get it cause you gotta confuse
them a little bit that's what you did
remember i told you on the phone the
other day you pay an attorney
what would we say in the airborne i
[ __ ] forget
i don't even remember are they confused
to confuse people to confuse people a
good jew of confusion you pay him to
stop confusing listen i don't want to be
confused oh yeah yeah i don't want to be
[ __ ] confused no more
let me give some shout outs real quick
to my main man in vegas freddie correa
and his wife
ed priolo
raphael fuentes
maglesto cologne ray majewski over there
on facebook smacking [ __ ]
jeremiah jones
james lee sacrantino
and young squee
i love you [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
so what are you gonna do in the next
couple of days without your uncle joey
the next couple days i have a math
therapy tomorrow i have another couple
podcasts this week
and uh i might go down to the podcast
festival this weekend i'm not sure about
that
and uh
that's really it i don't have another
mingle and [ __ ] maybe we'll see
this is a tough weekend for me my friend
why is that
that i go home i don't know why it
doesn't bother me
but it does bother me
well it doesn't bother me but it does
bother me
going home yeah
what about it gotta go to the cemetery
gotta drive around the neighborhood
gonna see all my old haunts
you realize how old you are
you know
you realize life moved on
all you have is your [ __ ] memories
you know
all i have is stupid memories of that
[ __ ] i cherish them more than anything
in the [ __ ] world
when i drive on 76th street and i'm
parking that light and i'm going to make
a left at the lex light on 77th to go to
loser's house
and i look over my right shoulder i
don't see hashtags there it just does
something to me you know it just [ __ ]
does something i don't break down
i don't need to go to a therapist
but it just uh it kicks you in the
stomach it kicks your youth in the
stomach it kicks uh who you were as a
child in the stomach
i didn't know anything as a kid i just
always thought hashtags would be there
yeah why wouldn't you yeah and again we
all were talking about this not last
night
the podcast before we all have our own
hashtags
we all have memories of that [ __ ]
childhood deli or pizza place or chinese
place or whatever the [ __ ] that you were
in there and you tortured the people and
they gave you credit and
one day you swallowed a [ __ ] roach in
there by mistake and they didn't tell
nobody they gave you free food for the
rest of your life whatever for me
i'll say that name for the rest of my
life hash ways you know
i had a lot of [ __ ] fun in there but
tomorrow i get to go home and i'll drive
by at night and
i just shake my head
you know i always go down by my mother's
bar
and make a right on burger line that i
left on burger land avenue and i see
what that's like now
and that's completely different then i
hook a left on new york avenue when i
shoot all the way up to like [ __ ]
48th and i got all over the [ __ ]
hudson avenue
and i go all the way to 60th and i make
a [ __ ] left down to kennedy boulevard
and i hit veneers
and i see what it looks like at night
then i make a [ __ ] run up
i got the same route every time dog
really
sure because that's the route i had as a
child i don't know
and that's it i don't get out i don't
breathe the air
i just take that one ride to see
what happened
to kick me in the stomach just to
shoot whatever dreams i had done that i
was like i have to go back to jersey
it's going to be the same you know
what would you even want it to be the
same
like would you love it would you love it
if everything was the same
a part of me i'd like to to be like a
twilight zone episode
a part of me would like to be going back
there
and uh to see nick still being alive and
mr and mrs hashway still being alive
and still being able to go in there and
get a roast beef sandwich on rye with
the lettuce sliced real thin and heavy
on the salt no heavy on the pepper and
light on the salt
mayonnaise with a little tomato you know
and get a bag of wise potato chips or
some macaroni salad and a 16 ounce
coca-cola [ __ ] yeah
and then for dessert i would get a
yoo-hoo and two yodels you know those
chocolate things
you didn't [ __ ] around from the
beginning though oh my god and on big
days you went in there and
big days like let's say you were [ __ ]
lifting [ __ ] weights or something i
would go in there and get the [ __ ]
roast beef on the sub sandwich
with lettuce and vinegar oil and swiss
cheese like a [ __ ] i would get
the the macaroni salad but instead of
the chips
i switch it up to the pepperoncinis in
the [ __ ] jar
and you just oh get a [ __ ] jaw for
249 why [ __ ] around one of those little
pepper chips she'd have them on the
shelves you tack it onto your [ __ ]
bill and while you're biting into that
roast beef sandwich with [ __ ] swiss
cheese
you're taking that pepperoncini and
you're biting in half of it shoots in
your [ __ ] eyeball and the other half
drips down your face you know what i'm
saying and you wipe it with a napkin
that's [ __ ] living jack
would i eat one of those tomorrow mrs
hashway is still there yes
that's the first place i go when i get
off the [ __ ] plane tomorrow night
but it's not there anymore it's not
there no longer
[ __ ] uh they had the big cube in
place it had been there for 30 [ __ ]
years
closed down last year that's it over
i think no i didn't take it i had to get
to a different cubing place that place
is done ash race is done chance dragging
in is still [ __ ] holding tough
you could still go in there and smell
chinese puke from 1987.
have they have they changed the decor at
all not a [ __ ] wink you understand me
that's what makes me love it even more
[ __ ]
but i just uh you have this for me i
have an empty feeling could you imagine
going back to your neighborhood and your
mom's not there and your dad's not there
and your old house somebody lives in
your house someone they painted my house
a new color you can't even knock on the
[ __ ] door but
ten years from now they you'll want to
go over there and just knock on the door
one day excuse me my name is lee this is
my wife paula
i'm a producer and my wife's an attorney
i grew up in this house do you mind that
me and her come in and show my child
where we grew up you know
i don't have that i could never knock on
that door never or you should we tried
we went over it you and i we looked in
the backyard yeah we were there and it
didn't do anything to me that night that
day with you
but a few days later i remembered where
i had walked and i kind of gave me an
anxiety attack
because those bricks were still there
the grass had grown between them
remember
those bricks were the same ones i played
on
in 1979 bounced the basketball off
that's how i learned to dribble bouncing
the basketball over there
so you don't think you can handle it
going inside the house
no
i don't think i could have gone inside
the house
again
i want it to stay the way it is in my
mind
i want that [ __ ] room i lived in that
room was a girl's room
why was it a girl's room
i don't know when the people who owned
the house before that had a daughter and
that was the [ __ ] room so when i
walked in there was girls who would talk
wallpaper and they had mirrors in there
and they had a girl's closet i just
moved and i didn't give a [ __ ] it was a
girl's uncle joey's room now
i would hate to see that room today you
know i had my trophies in there and my
[ __ ] record player and they had a tv
in there and i had my little kid bed in
there you know
i think if i went in there i'd go wow i
didn't remember being this small
right oh yeah it was huge when you're a
kid you know if i went up to the attic i
guarantee that they never figured out my
secret [ __ ] hiding spot in the closet
you think there could still be stuff up
there yeah yeah i know there's still
stuff up there
then we have to go
no no no
you know what man sometimes it's better
to leave something alone
trust me what i'm telling you i went
down there when i was with
my daughter last year i took her down
and i walked around with them i took
them to the [ __ ] park i played that
i had a great time with them i didn't
break down physically or mentally enough
i thought i would lee
see right now sometimes i think oh my
god this is going to be hard on me today
[ __ ]
and they [ __ ] i breeze right [ __ ]
through it
me going to the comedy store on stage or
going up to do comedy at the red [ __ ]
the black horse gives me more anxiety
than all those situations
you know i thought when i would walk
into the high school a few years ago and
have a nervous breakdown no that should
happen
none of that [ __ ] happened i don't know
how i dealt with italy
over the years doing all that coke and
sitting there alone like a [ __ ] loser
and writing about my past all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] cleared the air in my mind i
don't know how
i don't know how when i walk in the
streets a little bit sometimes i go wow
i remember walking on the street
after i did this i remember walking on
the street after i did that or what you
know i still remember walking that
walking that street when my godfather
was chasing me i still remember that
route i took and every time i go down
the loops or i just take a ride down
that hill i see all that [ __ ] and i go
jesus christ
30 years ago
i was getting chased in that [ __ ]
parking lot chased
chased you know that's that's [ __ ]
i haven't gotten chased you know i think
i got chased
four or five years after that but i
haven't been chased since then
i was getting chased
chased for [ __ ] four or five ounces
of coke
chased
now i pull up to my house
you know i look at the baby i look at my
wife and i go what the [ __ ] happened
do you see yourself being like you see
yourself running
i see my the reason why i only go home
for three days is because i don't want
it to sink in
because let's face it we know what the
[ __ ] it was you know
i left there because uh i had no other
option
in any direction there was no way i was
gonna make it out
no way
no way
do you ever get worried going back that
someone who didn't like you then is
gonna try to no no
you know this is 30 years ago me
i'm the only one that lives in that
stupid world
it was 30 years ago these people belong
no not too many people have a memory
like i do you know
i feel bad about the things i did but
it's not even that it's not i'm not even
talking about that
i'm talking about there was nothing i
could do like there was nothing i could
do i was worthless to myself there was
nothing i could [ __ ] do at that time
you know i couldn't get a job i was not
gonna hold the job down i don't care how
much you paid me or what the benefits
were
eventually i'd find the [ __ ] gripe i
was one of those guys
they only gave us 28 minutes for lunch
i'm walking why you they're giving you
22 an hour
i was one of those [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying right nothing was good
enough no i just wanted to be a [ __ ]
a junkie you know what i'm saying like i
wanted to dick around nothing was going
to be good enough
so i wanted to really put myself to the
test
in more ways than one i said the only
way i'm going to straighten out
is if i start from [ __ ] scratch
but nobody knows me where i got to get
up in the morning i can't go on anybody
go league let me borrow 300 till next
month
i'll figure out something to rob before
now and then i'll give you that 300 back
i had to start from scratch
i forced myself in a lot of ways when
i'm writing about this situation i think
back to that like i was like you know
what
if i don't [ __ ] leave i'm not gonna
do nothing here
let me leave
i got a couple [ __ ] pair of pants i
got some shirts i got some razors i got
some hair gel
we get a job
we get a job at least i got a place to
stay we got a job
i could always do something
and i always had that confidence that i
could fill out an application and
[ __ ] my way and boom i could always
get a job
for eight ten bucks an hour i wasn't
worried about that [ __ ]
but i knew leaving was the answer just
to really push myself
and in a lot of ways i wanted to fail i
wanted to fail so i had to come back to
that environment and really [ __ ]
failed you know what i'm saying
but you tried when you were in colorado
it's not like you sabotage well i guess
maybe you did sabotage yourself
in the end well if you really think
about it when i got arrested it didn't
let me do what i wanted to do was to go
home
in 1987 i was hell-bent on [ __ ] going
home so i lasted two years
all right i lost the [ __ ] in two years
you know these people that go home and
then come back and go like you know like
i lasted two years i didn't even make
ashley's [ __ ] turn
i left in june of 87 right
and no june of 85
in october of 87 i wanted to go back to
jersey
and no job no nothing i probably had
thirty five four thousand the bank i was
gonna go home
and try to be a coke dealer that's the
honest to god truth why didn't you like
colorado anymore
because i couldn't be immediately
i didn't have none of my idiot friends
to go [ __ ] to the track with and you
couldn't do none of that stupid [ __ ] i
couldn't get hash ways
who knows what the mind [ __ ] was but i
know the mind [ __ ] was cocaine
i do know that i don't know what the
other mind [ __ ] was
but i knew though the main [ __ ] was
going back with my loser buddies and
snorting coke because that was their
realm
october of 87 was their [ __ ] realm
i was 25 years old and i was dying to be
a [ __ ] stiff
and if you think about it when i got
popped that forced me not to go home
they just kind of [ __ ] up going to
jail far away from where you were born
yeah
no [ __ ] like yeah we've talked about it
before like you were in colorado for a
couple years there's people who probably
go on vacation and go to jail in [ __ ]
a weird state i can't imagine going like
i was listening if i would have gone to
if i would have gone to okay
i got to [ __ ] colorado the first time
in april of 83.
i started clipping like in june i lasted
like maybe 90 days without clipping
something and then i couldn't restrain
myself it was all over the place and
then i moved to snowmass
and i went on a [ __ ] thievery [ __ ]
rump
you know it was like getting worse and
worse and i couldn't control myself i
was like [ __ ] the ice man instead of
killing people i was just robbing
you know if it wasn't a stake it was a
lobster tail it was something it was
just but what it was was my [ __ ]
wanting to get arrested
i had no fear i would go into a [ __ ]
supermarket with a pillow case
and my friend and i'd spend ten dollars
but i'd rob them for 40.
i'd get a steak but i'd have two steaks
in the bag and a salami and a [ __ ]
chicken
where's the pillowcase i would have it
like a duffel bag and it looked like i
had books in there
oh no no lee please lee please anyone
say let me see your bag never cause i
smiled and talked about football and we
[ __ ] talked about this and this and
what were you taking on sunday and come
on by and watching the [ __ ] mechanic
you know it was always stupidity
so i always got away with that little
[ __ ] uh
i would go in the supermarket and they
would never [ __ ] ask me you know
jesus christ that's i would always be
true
and then the cops were on to me but not
really and i boogied before they could
really research
and i stayed out of there for 18 months
and then i went right back
and i didn't i wasn't the klepto when i
went back i was in the klepto when i
went back
by that time i was on to a different
from t and don't get me wrong i would
steal a pair of skis and sell them to
you for 50 if you want to go back to
boston
oh yeah if you came from boston you go
do you know what there's any skis around
here for a small nickel
let's not get your two thousand dollar
pairs knees with a small neck or what
size you want 175 boom they'll be in
your [ __ ] bag on the way back to
boston with you i swear to god there was
a lot of that [ __ ] going on where would
you steal skis from people would leave
them out to [ __ ] dry overnight and
you come by these are the ones i was
looking for
what a coincidence
oh my god and they sit there like they
come out and that was security at the
hotel
that was security from five to one so i
would steal them at ten after one would
you like see cool designs and like make
sure you knew what room they were in or
no because i would walk around and have
to drive around and they would all leave
their skis in little holes
and i would see the ski and i would call
my buddy and go dawg i saw those skis
you wanted
what size i don't [ __ ] know come by
you know he would see him and he'd go
let's clip them and we clip them that's
it and the morning i'd be in there
[ __ ] ready to pick somebody up at the
airport man something happened to us
either that's not that good enough what
time do you work don't join one o'clock
did you see a skis i don't know i saw a
bunch of [ __ ] skis i'm just crazy
there's a bunch of skis out there you
sure you put them out there man i'm not
sure man
and next thing are you talking about
listen next time you go to the sport
caitlin tell them what joey sent you go
see [ __ ] i swear to god because my
neighbor was the guy that worked at
sport count
so you have them on each side of the
transaction please
jesus christ joey
how do you remember all this though
because i'm a [ __ ] disgusting
[ __ ] that's why
only disgusting people remember [ __ ]
like this
oh my god
scary way to live man
i would always be nervous
like i'm nervous just thinking about
that
you're in my thoughts a lot lately
you're in my thoughts a lot because i
look at your age
and i always go what the [ __ ] was i
doing at 28
and i go jesus christ lee is a complete
different human being lee is a human
being
you know this time you say to me man i
wish i had more of a social life i wish
i would have done things differently
i love the way you're living your life i
mean your percentages are low
you know your percentages for a lot of
[ __ ] are low it's not like you're
scratching at night or
you're looking for a fix i mean the
worst thing you'll do at night is go get
10 tacos
oh
that's the worst thing a guy like you
will do is get
i don't know 12 o'clock at night you
know what [ __ ] joe diaz [ __ ] dave
[ __ ] ball i'm getting a
pizza pizza
i'm getting the [ __ ] new cheese nuts
and i'm getting the garlic wings that's
the worst thing you would do to yourself
yeah pretty much you would never do
cocaine you would never do heroin you'd
never do a pill
you would eat an edible with me how do
you feel you did 1300 milligrams tell
the [ __ ] audience how we feel like i
feel pretty good it's like another day
at the beach out here with [ __ ] uncle
joey and [ __ ] lisa yeah it's a fun
night
but that i always compare what you're
doing
and what i was doing
and i never get mad at you i'm always
like boy he's on the right [ __ ] track
dog i'm trying to
i feel like i'm getting when this
podcast started four years ago i was
like
really lost a lot like i felt i was on
the equipment you know you weren't lost
you were getting out of college that old
guinness yeah society made you get a job
that you thought you really wanted to do
you caught yourself in a corner you kind
of liked it because you like being
inside you like having the snacks around
you and taking your shoes oh my god they
had so many snacks i'm rubbing your feet
but then you have any snacks that's
[ __ ] up [ __ ] snacks
we got stars you want to snack i'll give
you another star i'll give you a brownie
with 100 [ __ ] 80 milligrams that's a
snack we got here you want a bong hit
that's a snack
that's a good nutritional snack right
there
no and i look at your twin i look at the
agostino i look at uh
thomas easter i look at all these kids
you know well thomas thiess is a little
longer than the two
thomas east is 32. that's when i came
out here i had to be 32 33 i wasn't no
youngster when i came out here
i was competing against youngsters but i
was lost totally
when i came out here at 32 i was just
buying timely
so
uh
i always look at you guys and i go
they're doing [ __ ] tremendous because
deep down inside
the only way i can make a buck in those
days
was selling cars or selling drugs
i had a knack for it and i would
flip-flop like i don't really like
selling [ __ ] cars full-time if i had
to do it i did it i did it for eight
months at a time or a year at a time
but i always preferred selling coke
it was easier for me at that time it was
what i wanted to do but how much more
dangerous though
i had my own click lee we've gone over
this [ __ ] i know but if it was me you di
agastino listen if i was getting an
eight ball every day in those days and
you snorting the agostino snored and we
got one more guy
you guys would snort every day not
because you want it because you had no
option
i'd drop a line on you and then drop a
package on your boom i'd left you a 50
there i don't want it no take it because
you're gonna call me in two hours and
then i'm gonna be [ __ ] all the way in
[ __ ] the valley and then you're gonna
come take the [ __ ] thing
you just take it
there'd be a time you'd have six of
those things joey i can't take no more
thank you you're gonna need it it's a
good [ __ ] it's the [ __ ] from noriega
you guys are good guys you guys are
really decent you're college educated i
mean the agostino's half a momo but he's
a hustler and a half he's got that
[ __ ] arab blood or whatever he's
gotten them that
south uh sicilian blood so diagnostina
don't [ __ ] stop so
but that's how i judge you know i kind
of go what the [ __ ] that i have going on
compared to those guys
at 28
i couldn't even open the [ __ ]
computer guys
i didn't know what the [ __ ] computer
was at 28.
i knew how to pay the rent whatever my
rent was i kept it low
there was no way i had a car payment
everything i did was a borrowed car or a
rented car or somebody's friend needed a
car i always i never had a colleague
i didn't get a car until i was swoof
in my 30s i don't think
i had problems man
i just got sick and tired of having
[ __ ] problems
yeah
so for me going home
brings up a lot of those old [ __ ]
feelings you know just not nothing
i'm not going to cry [ __ ] nothing
like that i don't even cry at the
[ __ ] grave anymore i just go
sometimes i bomb my head sometimes the
tear comes out
but it's not like i have a nervous
breakdown like that i just go i bring
some flowers
sometimes i whip out a [ __ ] number
and blow some reefer on it
well it's obviously important to you
even though it freaks you out a little
bit
you know what man it's home
let's be honest
you did jiu jitsu
all the time laura's case scenario
you're going to [ __ ] grab him into
your guard that's it and hold him there
for a minute until you regain everything
whether he's punching you in the head
where he's trying to pass your guard
you're always trying to retain your
guard and then you get him in a
defensive hold you hold his collar and
you hold the sleeve
uh
that's home for me what the [ __ ] are you
kidding right
that was where it started and that was
where it ended that [ __ ] hole
if you really look at it that way
that was where it ended and that was
where it started
there was nothing in my life more real
than that
was throwing dirt on that [ __ ] coffin
there's nothing more real than that
that's as real as taxes [ __ ]
and that either [ __ ] either you you
[ __ ] fold
or you throw a [ __ ] ace you know and
you don't have a choice you have to
throw an ace at that age so i had to go
for it
if it wasn't for the drugs i think i
would have folded it and i did fall who
the [ __ ] my kid
i folded because of the drugs and i
folded it because
i folded because of the drugs
and i i didn't fall because of the drugs
do you know what they unfold
failed
i failed myself at that age i was i was
a thief you know
i did drugs
and i could have possibly done something
you know
but just the the whole crushing the
whole [ __ ] deal
so yeah when i go home i feel all those
things
i do some comedy friday and saturday and
we're back hell yeah
cause now it's a new home you know what
i'm saying so that's when i left i
didn't do stand-up comedy
when i left there i was [ __ ] doing
god knows what the [ __ ] i was doing
so that's how i judge a lot of this [ __ ]
by you younger guys
and what the [ __ ] you doing these guys
send me emails they don't know how lucky
they are
they send me emails asking me about you
know like they don't know what to do
that they should stay in school it's
their [ __ ] last semester i got a good
one the other day about last semester
and stuff like that
where you gonna go
you're already there right right why
drop out now well a lot of people do
that for some reason i don't know why i
i wouldn't i well i got no choice they
told me to drop out they transferred me
to a correctional facility
where there was three books that's it
what courses do you offer here there's
three of them all right they're sitting
in the library they're sitting in the
library
and they're sitting in the library and
reading the paper i'll take three i'll
take the third one also [ __ ] that [ __ ]
give me those papers there my brother
i wishly you could go to new york i just
have a lot on my dish in new york no no
no and you'd make me [ __ ] nervous
walking around because i couldn't even
imagine i couldn't even imagine what you
come to me with
next thing you know you go to staten
island for jewish food or something i'd
have to stab you
you know you went off the [ __ ]
plantation and whatever but you were in
good hands oh yeah it was a bobby shout
out yeah you're in good [ __ ] hands so
no no no it's always a fun [ __ ] time
at least
and besides your home with this week
with the mom you're going to go to
chicago and me to tape the special oh
yeah that's gonna be great i asked for
the hotel rooms today timmy holloway
hopefully he's gonna be able to [ __ ]
come so uh
you know i'm working really hard man
i'm not getting stressed out at all
about this this isn't
i told myself before i said yes there
was only one way to [ __ ] do this
and the good thing about this is i'm
having a good time doing it i had a good
time in austin lee oh yeah thursday my
first show lee you were there you my
witness i don't know what happened to
the show i ate dick
was i mad
no really no
there's no time
you're gonna have to get numbers [ __ ]
you gotta get some good ones and you
gotta get some bad ones there's nothing
i could do i still gotta do four more in
new york
five more in columbus
and then a three-show warm-up
before the two that i'm shooting for the
special
so what do we got we got four
we got five that's nine
and then we got three twelve and then we
got two at the comedy store 14 14 and we
got one at the ice house 15 15.
if i could get 12 tremendous and three
bombings it's going to be a good [ __ ]
special
it doesn't matter where the bombings are
in those 15 just
it always matters because i listened to
all of them thank god they get in the
tape this week i'm going to have to have
timmy holloway tape
i'll tape them one myself
yeah i'm learning a lot from taping
i can't live do you listen to the whole
thing i listen to half then i have to
put the other half it's too much for
uncle joey
and it's a bit much i can't lie to you
it's a it's tough
and that's [ __ ] up because it's
something no it's my voice and it pisses
me off
why does it piss you off because i wish
i had a nicer [ __ ] voice my voice
gets on my goddamn nerves
that's why i've been telling you this
[ __ ] years [ __ ] just something
about your own voice no yeah it's tough
to [ __ ] explain to people we talked
about this [ __ ]
but uh i'm i'm it's something i've never
done which
i could feel it on stage
i could i felt it in austin friday and
saturday on stage
and now i used to say things and get rid
of them
that's not happening no more
i'm saying i'm keeping them
and i'm building something so what i
thought wouldn't happen is [ __ ]
happening i'm getting
a tag every two or three shows
which is what you really want i was
scared of hitting an hour the last three
weeks i've been doing an hour 10
everywhere yeah you have so think about
it this is how i'm learning a lot and
i'm appreciating that you guys are
coming out and supporting me whether
it's at the ice house or at the [ __ ]
flappers or at the [ __ ] another place
where we're doing where else are we
doing black horse
the dark horse of course when you guys
come out those nights it's always
tremendous because
i just go up there talk and we tape it
and then we listen
and uh if we get one line from it it's
successful you guys are helping me out
you know what i'm saying
this week like i said i'm a gotham i
don't know what's left
i'm hearing rumors i don't know what's
left i hear saturday night's gone i hear
they got tickets for the early show
i hear friday early is gone i don't know
you gotta go down there and talk to
those [ __ ] people and see what's
going on or go on the gotham
website i don't know what it is
gothamcomedy.com
friday and saturday eight and ten
o'clock
and then next week the 29th i'm over at
the ice house there's one
three no expectation doors left
but i think the ice house i'm going to
do
the closest i'm going to do the special
is going to be wednesday at the ice
house hopefully lee will be there to
tape it absolutely and
that tape is gonna be really serious
because
that's what i'm gonna be working on in
jersey
is what that tape's gonna work like
and even if that close is not working
that's what i'm gonna have to put a spin
on [ __ ] and that's what shit's gonna get
[ __ ] tough
because that's what's lacking right now
is that final [ __ ] ba-bam
it's not really there it's going 50 50.
so i got to repolish that up and i'm
being honest very but i'm being as
honest as i can this makes me even want
to work more because now i put it out
there [ __ ] that's how uncle joey
works i come up here and tell you i'm
going to [ __ ] kill you [ __ ]
no no no no
this thing still needs a couple of
[ __ ] tweaks and a couple [ __ ]
twerks thank god lee was there lee's
good at stand up guys
liam's been watching stand up since he's
a young kid and i tell you what he picks
up little [ __ ] things
lee would be a good movie director
because he takes the best of what you
got he doesn't take your weak [ __ ] he
accepts it
and he goes no no but you did this this
time and last show you didn't do this in
this show you should do this leigh's got
a great idea too that i'm scared to do
but that's lee but that's what makes me
[ __ ] dangerous because i take lee's
[ __ ] advice
go up there feel like i want to shoot
myself and then i get off and i don't
get mad at me i just giggle we both
because i'll yell at him for five
minutes then we both got a [ __ ] laugh
that's the beauty of this whole goddamn
thing guys
uh
obviously you know me
in my [ __ ] suitcase right now as we
speak there's at least three the four
pam me on these well i used all four of
them i dotted my back is [ __ ] up so i
don't think i could work out or roll
around or do jumping jacks nothing like
that i think i'm just gonna walk around
with the bars rooting piece of my mouth
and trying out the stuff that you do to
get your lungs strong and [ __ ] like that
i saw him talking about it on rogan and
i ordered it
but uh no matter what man when i have
short time now i'm too old to walk
around without pair of underwear i just
feel real self-conscious
immunities is really comfortable well
i'm at that age now i got a daughter i
don't want to walk around my balls right
inside the side outside
so for me right now i got rid once my
undies came into my life i got
completely rid
of the [ __ ] cotton and all the boxes
in my life all that's in that drawer now
is [ __ ] me on these and
two or three want to be me undies that i
wear the jiu jitsu from time to time if
they're ripped or something like that
i gotta wear suit but whether you're
wearing a suit or sweats you spend
almost 24 hours a day in your underwear
but instead of making a statement like
superman's tights under his everyday
clothes
your wonderware is probably [ __ ]
boring all right
me undies they're here to change that
[ __ ] every pair of me on these is made
from
source modal a fabric that's twice as
soft as cotton okay pronounced modal
m-o-d-a-l
nothing can describe the fit
and feel of my undies once you try them
on you'll understand why they're called
the world's most comfortable underwear
and if you don't love your first pair of
me undies guess what they're free no
questions asked i personally love them
they keep the [ __ ] goo off your guck
they [ __ ] do the boop ball tap now
you want me to tell you what they do bro
they keep you dry inside that mall doll
really really really works
you put them on with a suit i wear them
specifically for jiu jitsu i want to go
on the elliptical or anywhere i'm
wearing uh
shorts to sweat i don't like sweating
down there it makes me feel real dirty
you know what might have these does the
trick so do me a favor me undies has
dozens of styles limited edition prints
to help you make a statement with your
underwear whether anyone can see them or
not remember superman
what we're going to do is shipping is
free in the u.s and canada and you could
save up to eight dollars a pair with me
undies subscription plan that's right
get the subscription or a single pair
and get 20 off your first order when you
go to meundies.com joey i'm telling you
right now 20 off your order when you go
to the undies dot com slash joey that's
meundies.com
slash joey for 20 off your first order
again go to me undies give it a shot
what do you got to lose you don't like
them we give you your money back and
then and beside that you got to take a
chance columbus did go to meundies.com
joey right now and get the party started
listen if you guys are as bad as i am
you know nothing about wine
i know nothing about one i walk around
the supermarket i just walk around in
circles the last couple bottles of wine
i bought i bought them because of the
price
or just to give somebody a nice gift or
whatever somebody tells me i like a nice
wine you buy it you give it to them for
christmas
and uh
you move on with your life all right
club w is a service that delivers wine
straight to your door we send you the
wine that is personalized to your
palette taste
through our palette quiz the
recommendations become even more
personalized with every bottle you rate
we work with top wine makers and growers
from around the world directly to make
all of our own wine it's high quality
it's 13 a bottle and it would normally
retail for 20 plus dollars you choose
the type and the quantity of bottles
with no membership free or no
cancellation fee and 100
satisfaction guaranteed we partner with
local artists and develop wine labels
that are unique works of art okay do me
a favor
i hear nothing but great things about
club w if you like wine and you really
enjoy you know sipping wine and putting
a hat on with a feather and looking out
into the ocean do yourself a favor this
is the wine for you right now club
office club w's offering listeners 20
off your first door to 20 dollars 20 off
your first order when you go to
clubw.com
joey again 20 off your first order when
you go to the club w dot com slash joey
and it gets better i know you hate
paying for shipping so club w will
actually pay for your shipping on orders
of four
bottles or more
so take something off your to-do list
for the holidays here you go it starts
right now just go to club w dot com
slash joey to get 20 off your first
order today right now that's club w dot
com slash joey today
thank you one more time to me undies
thank you to club w and thank you to our
main sponsor on it.com always there for
you supplements they got the the
training bars they got kettlebells they
got the gorillas they got life vest if
you need it they got it you want to make
your life change go to honor right now
you're walking around you're skinny
you're not getting hung up whatever the
hell is going on with you listen do
yourself a favor go to hunter.com get
some of that alpha bring get some of
that hunt protein get some of the nice
chocolate get yourself that new tct oil
the tcm oil people are loving that stuff
i'm having a great review get yourself a
little of the mixed greens whatever the
hell you want go to haunted.com right
now and look at the great list of
supplements that they have i push the
supplements because i get your 10 off so
go to honor.com there's something you
like go to the box and press in church
booyah c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 percent off i want to thank
meundies i want to thank
club w and i want to thank my main
people over there on it.com right now
and i want to thank you guys we'll be
back monday night eight o'clock shot
wednesday three o'clock in the afternoon
we're setting this [ __ ] train
up [ __ ] please say goodnight
goodnight everybody i love you
[ __ ] see you in new york city
we'll see you the following wednesday at
the ice house stay black
you